tu sais vous les copies de tout le monde
n'a pas envie de faire partie de votre
banque
[Musique]
excusez moi c'est pas parce qu'on est
dehors que vous pouvez expiré
tranquillement à la tête des gens c'est
criminel ce que vous faites attention
aux postillons faites attention monsieur
parce que les enfants c'est pire que les
pangolins comment ça je suis qu'un
contact mais c'est qui le contenu de la
choper bon bah si vous me dites pas
immédiatement qui s'est fait partout
c'est dans une rame de métro connaît pas
de gros je connais pas de vieux donc
j'ai pas de raison d'aller me faire
tester cette pole choqué vous avez plus
de doha ok merci beaucoup et j'aurai je
reste quand les résultats et du tout
cissé j'ai senti que ça a touché l'eau
n'arrive à merveille c'est pas ça souci
c'est que c'est censé la ventre rentré
jusque là voulaient me violer le nez en
fait
apparemment il ya cédric hervé renard
qui sont morts suite à la soirée qu'on a
fait tous ensemble on s'est dit c'est
pas bon ah non ah bah oui non mais on
n'a pas tous hugo vide
moi j'ai encore le goût c'est quoi comme
forme ça parce que ça c'est la forme
serviettes hygiéniques n'ont déjà que
c'est dommage de gâcher mon visage
bonjour monsieur on pour se faire
vacciner en tant que soignant
non il faut prendre rendez vous sans
doute au niveau même si on a 76 ans
j'aime pas trop cette marque de gel
j'ai l'impression que j'ai les mains qui
pue des pieds un peux pas vous le masque
bas et vous m'annoncez mois ben oui
c'est moche
ah oui
[Musique]